[Music]
[Applause]
hello my name is Steve so we've probably
gathered and I'm an instructor at the
turn school of software design out in
Denver Colorado what is that
whoo right that is a 7-month developer
training program where we take people
who don't know how to develop web
applications and we hopefully show them
how to develop web applications over the
course at seven months so if you're
interested mentoring people who are who
want to become developers please come
talk to me if you would like to hire
like six seven twelve developers also
come talk to me after this I've got
cards and all that other fun stuff
other kind of like administrivia is that
we're starting a node bots colorado
meetup on June 3rd so if you are in the
Denver Boulder region come visit and
hang out with us everything you can see
today lives in a little readme file on
this repo so you can play along if you
start playing with it while I'm talking
this is an audio talk and I'll know all
right so maybe maybe you wait until
lunchtime but everything is there along
with the slides and everything else so
as you probably gathered from the title
of this talk either a you're in the
wrong room or B you're here to hear a
little bit about making music with the
web browser and so I have a little
secret for you and I guess I'll just
kind of get this out of the way now is
that as it turns out somebody put a
synthesizer into your web browser it's
true so what does that mean it takes the
form of this fun thing called the Web
Audio API which say I'm just kind of
introduced you introduced us to a little
bit and I'm gonna go in a little more
detail with and how do we use this Web
Audio API
that's a great question I'm glad that
you asked it it starts with some context
so if you've ever worked with like html5
canvas or anything along those lines
you're familiar with this idea of like a
context it's like the canvas that you're
drawing on in this case it's the audio
graph that you're working with and in
most cases there is one audio context
per page so basically you create one you
spin it up and you start to hook
together your different audio nodes
how do we do that that is a great
question as well basically there is a
built in in the browser called audio
context there's a little bit of vendor
prefix silliness going on with Safari so
in order to support Safari we do this a
little quick trick on line 1 & 2 here
well we'll say hey give me your audio
context oh you don't have that well I'll
take your WebKit audio context either
way we'll do a little tomfoolery to get
the right one and then we can basically
accentuate it and now we have an audio
context that we can play around with the
news and what what is involved in audio
context well we need some way to like
get that audio out of our browser right
so we have this thing called a
destination and the metaphor I'm going
to use if you've ever played guitar it's
like your amplifier it's the thing that
you're plugging everything else into
technically speaking it's like the
operating systems audio whatever right
it's an amplifier it's your computer
speakers it's your earbuds it's whatever
we also need some kind of sound source
and we connect that sound source to our
destination and we can make sound
the other cool thing is that we can put
a whole bunch of stuff in the middle
right like FX pedal so if you're playing
guitar it would be a wah-wah pedal or
delay pedal or a chorus pedal right we
can take other audio nodes take whatever
the input source is do some processing
on it and then send that the kind of
processed version of our audio to the
destination and get to use it as well so
let's start by talking about the first
piece of this we want to get some sound
of the browser so we're going to need to
have we need to set up that audio
context destination and that is also
pretty easy to do that context that we
created in the last little code sample
it's got a bunch of properties and
methods on it
one of those is destination and that is
a representation of your audio context
destination it is your amplifier it is
what you're gonna plug other stuff into
and where sound is going to come out so
we've got we've got a destination and
now we need some kind of audio source
and we've got a bunch of options we
could load in some kind of sound file
that'd be cool
we could take something from the users
microphone and like analyze it and
process it along those lines or we can
generate our own tone
now we're talking about making music
with the browser right so the first two
are kind of off the table we don't want
to take a pre-recorded music and play it
that's been done right it was MIDI files
in the 90s it was on my Geo Cities page
I'm not embarrassed of that at all we
can also we don't also don't want just
like record other sounds and be able to
analyze it we want to actually make
sounds so our hero in this story too is
going to be the oscillator which you got
a little bit of an introduction to in
the last talk and an oscillator
basically creates a sound wave and a
sound wave is this kind of like
vibration in the air that your ear make
some sense out of and turns into a given
tone and there's some distance in
between each of the waves and the
amplitude which is how high the peaks
are and how deep the valleys are right
which for the for our purpose to say is
basically the volume how do we create an
oscillator again we've got some methods
on that context that we created before
and all we have to do is call create
oscillator and we have created an
oscillator and that's grades now we have
an oscillator and we've got a
destination what we do need to do next
is connect at the two of them we need to
take our keytar in this case and we need
to plug it into our amp in order to get
any sound out of it so we've got a few
more methods now we've got a method on
that oscillator and we can connect it to
the context destination so we're
plugging our keytar into our amp and
we're almost ready to rock and roll
almost because the other thing we need
to do is actually you know like hit some
keys on that keytar in order to play
anything so the other thing we need to
start our oscillator turn it on and have
it begin to create some sounds for us
and so that's pretty easy to do as well
how do we start an oscillator we call
start on it you might be wondering what
is this zero that is when you want it to
start how far in the future you want it
to start in this case we want it to
start right now Firefox and Chrome
totally okay with you omitting this and
Luis just started immediately Safari not
okay with this so we can put in a zero
saying hey I want to start this
oscillator and I want to start it right
now and that's great like you probably
messed up what frequency you want your
if you're like me your blow
not your eardrums right now with a super
high-pitched frequency congratulations
so now you probably want to stop it
surprise the method is called stop
here's where it gets tricky all right I
am done blowing out my eardrums I want
to adjust the frequency and I want to
start the oscillator again not gonna
happen right here's the kind of gotcha
on that once you stop an oscillator you
cannot restart it game over you have to
get rid of it and get a new one so you
might say to yourself all right yeah
I'll just generate another one no big
deal the other thing you want to make
sure that you do is disconnect that
oscillator that you had so that I can
get garbage collected if you don't
disconnect it the context destination
still is a reference to it it's still
hanging on memory you get a little out
of control and start doing that too much
congratulations you have a memory leak
don't have a memory leak disconnect your
oscillators when you're done that's the
responsible thing to do all right so now
it's gotten garbage collected we can
bring in a new one and here it is the
other thing we talked about before is
that we can connect stuff in the middle
so you might say I don't want to keep
creating and destroying oscillators it
seems seems reckless I'm not interested
in doing that it's actually pretty
efficient it's not a big deal but it
makes me feel a little dirty so the
other option is to plug in our sound
source into some kind of intermediary
node that will process that sound and in
this case if we use the gain node we can
basically turn up and down the amplitude
which for our purposes is the volume so
we can turn the volume down to zero and
yeah the oscillator is still running but
none of that sound is getting to the
destination which means for all intents
and purposes the thing is stopped that's
it and when we're ready to hear from it
again
we can turn the gain up to one which is
the kind of the default setting and all
of the sound will continue to travel
through so we got to get to like mimic
the idea which hernion oscillator on and
off but really we're just adjusting into
a intermediary gain node instead how do
we do that there should be no surprises
here context has a few other methods for
generating all the other intermediary
nodes that we might need in this case
we'll create a game
and we can then hook up our guitar to
our game node so we'll connect the
oscillator to the gain node then we'll
hook the game node up to our destination
and now we can start the oscillator and
we can just adjust the volume to kind of
give the illusion that we're turning it
off and on but in fact we're just simply
adjusting again an intermediary node so
again we we knows what we're talking
about the oscillator oscillators got a
bunch of other properties too it's what
frequency should what should be the
bandwidth of those waves right how close
together a far apart should they be but
a default we get a later that is at 440
but we can adjust it down to 220 we can
adjust it up to like 8,000 don't do that
if you weren't headphones again I don't
know if you there was a malls in the UK
a few years ago would play super
high-pitched tones because as you get
older you can't hear those so like it
would be for the sole purpose of scaring
away teenagers right so there's a use
for this in your practical everyday life
when you want teenagers to go away
create an oscillator at a super high
frequency and turn it on you might also
scare away your dog and cat that could
be a bonus depending on how you feel
about them at that moment so we have a
bunch of different types of waves right
this is basically the shape of the wave
we get a few out of the box by default a
sine wave is this kind of nice curvy
happy wave if it sounds pretty Pleasant
to the ears a square wave gets the same
from looking like squares a triangle
wave gets the same from looking like
triangles and a sawtooth looks like a
saw alright there's not like a lot of
like heavy like vocabulary here it's
like hey that's what that wave looks
like and you can use any of those if you
want you can also create your own custom
waveforms that are different than those
but those are kind of the default
traditional like synthesizer sound waves
that we've had available since like the
70s and we can basically oscillator has
a property on it where we can change it
to whatever type of wave that we want so
let's actually take a look at this we
look at a little example where we can
kind of create an oscillator
we there we go I can adjust the gain
here
and so this is a sine wave and we could
change the frequency
[Music]
and you see as the frequency increases
then in that case the but it had a pitch
to our ears sounds higher we also I'm
gonna go back down to 220 for everyone's
benefit
because I care
and we can try out a square wave
captain at 4:40
so too
and a triangle so the shape of the wave
has different tonal properties to our
ears and we can kind of change one for
the rest of this talk we're gonna be
going with the nice sine wave because
it's probably the most pleasant cool so
at this point we now know how to make
sound and that's super cool and but
sound is necessary but it's not
sufficient for making music right so
it's called the Web Audio API not the
web music API it's going to help us make
some sound but it's on us to turn that
sound into some music so we're gonna
need to know a few things about music in
order to get this working so we talked a
little about the default frequency of an
oscillator is 440 440 if you've ever
seen like one of those tuning forks that
is a four and it's kind of like the what
we base most of our just general tones
on most Western musical instruments so
we got 440 if we were to double that
frequency to 880 conveniently we would
get a 5 which is an a note but an octave
higher and if we were to have 442 that
220 we had before we would have a but an
octave lower I don't know if you know
this but there are more notes than just
a so we have these things called
semitones and it's the 12 like units in
between two octaves and again that's
simply a western music thing it's not
like a physics law or anything but we
have decided that these are the tones
the sound reasonably Pleasant to our
ears and some of them have some basis in
like actual physics if you take a guitar
string and put your finger in the middle
and play a harmonic of the middle of
string that is usually one octave higher
if you put it a third of the way through
you'll get a fifth so on and so forth so
you get some of the basic ones and we
kind of filled in the gaps so you might
say yourself alright well if I wanted to
get the rest of these notes I'll use
math and that seems really reasonable
cuz at first glance it works right so
this is simply we've got a for it for 14
if we look a and octave up it's 880 and
if we divide by you know 1 12 steps each
way we get there no big deal
sounds like it sounds great
unfortunately it only works in one key
right if you were to start at C you
you see almost immediately the notes
don't match up so if you were to use
this kind of mathematical approach you
could create an instrument that only
sounds good in one key and that's you
know you it's called a harmonica right
you buy a whole bunch of them and you
never learn how to play them and that's
you know kind of how it works but so the
first thing I tried to do is like
alright I'm smart
reasonably I can figure this out
so I'll come up with an algorithm that
I'll like work unfortunately this is
like a problem that humans have been
working on for like thousands of years
and I was not able to figure out on one
Red Bull fueled afternoon however it
occurred to me that you know what I'll
do I'll just steal an approach that
already works like we have figured this
out this is a solved problem right so
that going by units of 112 is equal
temperament the other approach is to use
this thing called just intonation which
is a bunch of ratios that are
compromises between all the keys so no
one is not perfect right and like the
kind of like physical sense of and in
the way of equal temperament but it is
reasonably good in every key but not
perfectly accurate in any of them right
so we can steal something from the piano
so now I just needed a way to get from
piano tones and piano frequencies and
just steal a little cheat sheet from
that and be able to use it and as I was
doing more and more projects doing this
each time just keeping a giant hash
table in a file and like trying to
reference it was getting obnoxious so
when you have a need and a possible
solution and you have a cute name for a
project you have an open-source library
this is a little library called octavian
and basically what it does is you can
hand it a just a general note and what
it'll do is it'll give you the frequency
it'll also give you all those things
that you might need to use about it like
what key on the piano is and all it does
is basically reference the lookup table
of like this note on the piano this
would be this frequency the other fun
thing that it does is it lets you
actually do the different intervals
between notes so like a major chord is a
root note it's a major third and a
perfect fifth a minor chord is a root
note it's a minor third and a perfect
fifth so you can kind of like reason
about these notes and get everything you
need along the way all right so now
we've we can create sound and the other
thing we can do
is we can reason about it in terms of
music let's actually build a musical
instrument so this is a little example
instrument called audio phonic and let's
take a look Adam I was going ladies
gentlemen and I'm sorry it's going to
place a song more like a JS synthesizing
so as you can see we can hover over a
bunch of notes and it'll play tones and
if we press a key it'll actually like
activate that tone so we've created a
musical instrument that's great how
exactly did we do that so the trick here
is we basically spun up a bunch of
oscillators and hook them all up to gain
nodes and on different events will
simply turn one of those on and off so
when a key gets pressed that will listen
for a key down event when that key down
event happens what we'll do is we'll say
alright I have this like synthesizer
object till I get me an oscillator for
c3 and it will go ahead and look up do I
have one in this let notes hash no if I
don't have one what it'll do is go and
put one in there for me very I'm caught
up
and then return it out now real
synthesizer usually is like three
oscillators that it's adjusting the
frequencies on and turning on and off
but I've got 16 gigs of ram and I'm
gonna treat myself to like 80
oscillators because I can do that
alright so I'm just gonna keep them all
in hash and if I have one great use it
if I don't have one make it put it in
the table and then use it as well and
you might say like what does this new
oscillator thing it's just a little
abstraction and all it does is like grab
it creates an oscillator in a gain node
it sets some default values on them in
this case the frequency that I wanted an
oscillator for it'll hook them up
together it'll start it return it out to
me and I've got these start and stop
methods that are not actually starting
step methods on the oscillator but on
that gain node so for me I feel like I'm
working with an oscillator but there's
just a few more things happening in the
middle so then we can say alright if we
hit the button that's bound to c3 get me
an oscillator for c3 start it and when
they take the thing when they do a key
up event will simply send it off and
we'll stop that oscillator and that's
all we need to do to create a very small
since it's synthesizer nothing like
saying that in front of 600 people so
that's cool but that's only like why
wouldn't you just buy a keyboard at that
point right why did you need to do all
this about me it's fun totally you can
share with your friends that will start
using at night and they're great to come
up on stage and play a song in front of
everyone that's awesome but like why
else would we want to use something like
this well the other really kind of
interesting part is that somebody put a
web browser in your synthesizer right
that's not the only API that's available
in in the browser so the fun comes in
when we start mixing and matching
different api's so one example is we can
mix the Web Audio API with the
getusermedia API my favorite slide
coming up this little app called face
theremin are you guys all familiar with
what a theremin is it's like the things
of making the spooky like 60s like UFO
music and you're like lift your hands
over some things I thought hey it would
be really cool if I could do that with
my face so what we'll do
I can't actually see myself here
hold on
in fairness most of the hard work there
is being done by the head tracking
software so it detects your face and
when you move your face it emits a face
tracking event right which it has a
whole bunch of properties on it I really
only care about two of them right now
you might care about other ones but
height and the x value the X is the only
horizontal where am I in this direction
or that direction and the height is how
close to how far I am
and I'll take those two properties and I
will like do some like simple math to
like make sure that they're reasonable
frequencies and gain amounts and then
I'll take my oscillator my gain value
and I will like adjust them accordingly
and that's really all there is to it I
mean there's also the entire face
tracking library but that's somebody
else's problems and then lastly I will
like bind myself to that event and like
update stuff along those lines okay so
now we're seeing the real power here is
what we can mix and match other api's
what about WebSockets all right so you
might say like cool we can have a intern
with a bunch of people can play in real
time together there is some latency so
you don't want a bunch of people like
moving their heads together or something
like synchronize head movements or maybe
even playing like keyboard tones because
there's going to be some latency and the
other part about music that I never had
was rhythm so like that's gonna be an
issue with like the latency thing but we
can kind of address that by using what's
called a step sequencer right a step
sequencer we've got 16 quarter notes
which I have zero indexed because this
is a JavaScript conference and they are
quarter notes and we'll kind of step
through each and every one of those and
then the rows are a bunch of musical
notes in this case I have only chosen c
g c e g and a because it is very
difficult for you to make a melody that
sounds bad what's that I mean you could
probably do it I believe in you
but it makes it like when you have
multiple people playing so now what we
can do is anytime somebody activates a
square on the grid we send that over
WebSockets to little like Express socket
IO server that will then take that
sequence Matt
with all the other ones it has and
pushes out to all the other connected
clients and what we'll do then is when
it gets to the client we'll take all the
sequences and we'll for the user
sequence will like make those the bright
yellow for everyone else we'll make them
this pale color will render all the
other sequences below but we'll then
combine them all to one sequence that'll
get played out so be everyone's music
together
so let's actually take it for a spin now
you know what's coming next alright so
here we've got a sequencer and I happen
to like have an iPad over here to be my
other my other set of ears so I can
begin to unmute and I'll start playing
like a bass line this is so hard when I
can't see watch me do it alright so I've
got a bass line going hmm just so you
believe me
iPad so I can start playing a melody
here
[Music]
there's season playing on the iPad
here's the code base line that I put
down in my browser and they're all being
connected
ideally you would have tens twenties
hundreds of people kind of creating
music together around the world as well
and there's a link to this in the repo
that opposed to beginning I'll have at
the end so I totally encourage you
during lunch fire it up and let's have a
jazz come song it's only gonna be four
measures long and made it are four
different notes but whatever all right
so that's cool but so far we've also
like been a little bit limited by what
we've been able to do on the screen so
we've kind of had to either like bounce
stuff to the keyboard which is kind of
cool but also kind of difficult because
that's not a musical instrument and
where we've been able to like click on
different things as we know JavaScript
runs on the client it runs on the server
it also runs on hardware which means we
can begin to build our own musical
instruments right I've got a very small
example we're gonna switch to in a
moment but it means you can build like a
Nintendo Power glove there's an 80s
reference by the way and then dead no
power glove where every like pinch of
the fingers started to play a different
note it means you can use all the other
sensors that's on an r2 available for
Arduino and like begin to create
hardware musical instruments programmed
in JavaScript that work with the web Web
Audio API in the browser so this is a
really clear diagram of what I've got
going on here and I'll explain this but
basically we got some buttons and we've
got a little potentially ammeter and
whenever we hit one of the buttons
that'll send a signal to Johnny v Johnny
v will then has an express and will
socket I'll so ever running alongside of
it which is incredibly easy to do by the
way and we'll send that data over a
WebSocket to the browser and the browser
will then update and start playing the
right tone based on the button that we
hit so here we can say all right I'm
gonna listen for pins two four six and
eight they're you know I'm just gonna
keep them in in this quick little object
over here I'm gonna say when the button
is down it will send whatever key that
and whatever button that was and we'll
send that as true when the button is up
we'll send one saying it's false
basically the status of the buttons on
my board I'm sending them out to the
browser and then the potential meter is
going to like as we turn it go through
all the notes between c3 and c5 all
right so let's check out the demo
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool so basically at this point now that
we can build our own hardware that
creates music in the browser with
JavaScript there's very like limitless
possibilities and so the moral of the
story is that music is pretty awesome I
think we can all agree on that the web
also pretty awesome music and the web
together are like ice cream and cookie
dough each individually awesome but
exponentially more awesome when put
together and we only kind of scratch the
surface there's a bunch of other really
cool api's there's the gamepad API there
is WebRTC so you could theoretically
create multi-faced theremin there is the
gyroscope accelerometer API and mobile
devices there is the device orientation
API and there's also mixing and matching
more of the different examples that we
already went over right so there's a
bunch of limitless possibilities for you
to create musical instruments that have
never existed before so I kind of want
to encourage you to do that on the page
that has the links to everything we if
you make something really cool please
send me a pull request and we'll put a
link below and let's like collect all
the really cool musical instruments that
you make in the next days weeks and
months and with that thank you very much
[Music]